so what was this like season 1 I visited
you guys in the set back in like October
and it seemed like a blast did you guys
have fun what was it like you shot in
New Orleans so it's kind of a little bit
like you're in location it was like camp
how was it
first season a man I miss New Orleans
New Orleans so much you spend so much
time in New Orleans no it was so fun I
mean coming back well last season was
obviously sorority in this season's
hospital and we shot in New Orleans last
year and now we're in LA so it's so
weird cuz it's like we're all the same
characters and we're back to work but
it's all different so it's a little bit
of like a weird scream queens twilight
zone I mean Emma did you do you have a
favorite there are so many great Chanel
kind of takedown speeches or you know
like just you know where she tears and
people do have a favorite one I mean
well I mean just one like I love idiot
hookers that's come into my real life a
couple times calls me an idiot hooker
now because I'm the one that put it so I
give it back to them but no I mean I
loved when she's you know when she
Janelle has kind of fallen from grace
and she's doing her slo-mo walk and
everyone's throwing stuff at her that
was really fun to shoot and and yeah I
like that I like that little speech yeah
that's fun
Jamie Lee we sort of saw on the in the
clip you recreated your mother's psycho
scene I was actually there on set for
that day to remember yeah it was
incredible how did this come about I
mean that must have been I'm sure you've
been asked to do that but have been
asked to do it and for a long long long
long long time I've just felt that that
was sort of her domain to sort of be in
the shower and that it was hers and I
had it had nothing to do with me and
even though I was in horror films it
didn't matter it was hers and I really
respected her I miss her I
um she was known for that that was her
most iconic moment of her life and I
always felt that that was not something
I should participate in and then you
know cut to many many years later I'm an
old lady now I've got grown kids I've
been in show-off business for a very
long time I'm doing a show called scream
queens and it was actually proposed by
the boys and I read it in the script and
at that moment I thought about my mom
and I thought you know my mom would love
this she would have loved the show she
would have loved auda Lee who youngins
she would have loved you she would have
loved comic-con so to know she didn't
get that she didn't know what this was
and I think she would have just embraced
it and said she would have loved it she
would have been there on set and the
thing that was very weird is that you
know obviously I said I'd like to try to
do it as faithfully as possible now
obviously they shot that for two weeks
yeah and we had three hours so it's
obviously not gonna be shot for shot but
we did recreate it pretty pretty
accurately and there was one moment
where they had the video monitor of me
in the shower and then they had her
shower scene on a video player backstage
and really it was sort of like okay
raise your arm up no no her arms lower
now tip your head back
okay that's matching okay shoot and that
was a little eerie when you see that
side-by-side that's definitely a little
strange but it was beautiful but that
was very we were we I think we had had
an idea to do a much more subtle thing
and it was Jamie Lee who came and was
like no let's do I said if we're gonna
do it let's do it let's do it in black
and white and let's do it shot by shot
and let's get in the shower and and we
did and by the way that's but the unsung
hero here is the technical staff of our
show who really are extraordinary people
and Joaquin Cedillo is our DP
he and the art department they matched
the tile in the shower I mean they
really went above and beyond to make
that special and it was very emotional
for me and I'm very happy to have done
it and I'm so glad you guys loved it
yeah he and I want to recreate the scene
she did in True Lies yeah
I like that yeah sure but typically you
also that same day because I was there
you had the crazy fight scene with the
three Red Devils and Antonin Scalia and
you you did it like I was there you did
those stunts how long did that take to
learn you know what it's fun this is the
best job ever in the frickin world can
you imagine I get paid for this so for
me it was just super fun it was fun to
learn and you're playing it's just a
great job if you want to be an actor go
for it
it's a really fun job yeah Leah I got a
lot of questions on Twitter about did
you what was I mean Esther was such a
different role for you did you it was
almost like two different people
basically because by the end you see
she's not sort of this kind of bizarre
woman she's putting on this act what was
that like to sort of have two different
almost two different personalities it
was so much fun I mean I was so excited
when Ryan told me about scream queens
and so grateful that he Brad and ian
created this really exciting role for me
to play and all he told me was neck
brace and that was that but it was so
fun you know playing her as tester with
a neck brace and then Hester with the
makeover and then the real Hester
underneath it all growing up with gigi
and boone and then finding out that I
was the Red Devil which I didn't even
know to like the day before we started
filming and you actually talked with me
I know cuz I read this quick
[Laughter]
and mio you know you two red devil I was
like who's the killer she's like it's
you I was like oh my god do I die she's
like no you get away with it I was like
thank God yeah so when did you so you
guys found out you didn't find out - who
the Red Devil was till the very end like
nobody kept the pages like they were
they would give us the first act and
then we were waiting on the rest of the
pages and like literally they were
coming out the very week we were
shooting my experience is that these TV
shows that people are falling in love
with you guys don't want to know what's
happening and the whole idea that media
is so accessible and so immediate that
it's important you've got to keep
secrets I just want to know possibly can
know but what I'm saying is it's just
it's the way it's done now I'm sure all
these shows I mean you can speak to that
obvi print on red pages so it can't be
photocopied you try to limit it you
never know how stuff gets out but it
gets out we had the problem on Glee to
where it would just be scripts would
just feel like fully in PDF form on the
internet I don't know how that would Wow
wait that's why they did on red pages I
thought it was just because it was like
blood wait so who did you guys think
they've read who did you think the
killer was who was everyone's got it was
Oliver yeah we grace we also I mean we
were just constantly talking about it
that's it's it's fun it's as much it's
like you guys don't know we didn't know
and we would we were on the show and
we'd all be sitting around talking about
it and people would walk behind it are
you guys talking about who the killer is
like you're on the show and we still
didn't know so I thought it was me I
thought it was you for a minute but then
I did it didn't want they also do you
toy between there being like one killer
or two or three like didn't you there
was a yeah we we always had a gut from
the very beginning we had you told us
that which was a strong idea and then
wanted to leave some room open so there
were always two or two or three choices
we could have gone but we ended up we
were able to not paint ourselves in a
corner more able to go with our original
instinct so yeah we knew pretty
but it's always helpful particularly TV
it's such an interactive medium that you
want to leave yourself room to wiggle a
little bit yeah who between you and Ryan
and Brad is obsessed with Waterfalls by
TLC because that not so much play no
that's right that's one Ryan Ryan David
Murphy Wow Ryan Murphy loves waterfalls
yeah yeah well he'll know why I got
casted cuz of crazysexycool that's the
only reason why I got the job yeah
Kiki one of my favorite I think one of
my favorite relationships on season one
was you and me see zayday i thank you
guys so much for letting me have the
opportunity to work with her like that
what was that like where i mean you guys
just got along so well and you just were
so funny together well i mean how was
that working together i mean it was
really cool because an easier the kind
of person that you know you just watch
her and she just goes so it's really
cool to kind of just try to learn from
her see how she was able to pick up so
much in a second from what they wrote
and add billions of things on to it it
just it was magnificent to watch and
then to play with her it gave me the
confidence to kind of go out of my
comfort zone and try something too and
it really is the whole the whole gag
with the show yes that everybody
inspires you with their energy and their
bringing something crazy to the plate
because we read the script and we're
like how did they write this how can i
play this how can i make it just as good
as it is the page Billy do you when you
see your muffs now are you like are you
like oh like do you have like every time
I see a pair earmuffs I'm like I need
that right now so if you have a pair of
earmuffs I'm gonna take them from you
it's comfort yeah it's like a little
security blanket for my ears it's
beautiful and you get to ignore us was
that fun no because I mean she's a
number three it was so her back store
was so confused and that could be such a
surprise such a surprise was that sort
of fun to learn I mean did you know all
of that going in like you know that she
was Charles Manson no I had no idea but
I always felt it somewhere inside
because I feel like I'm Charles Manson's
daughter sorry dad I love you so much
but emotionally I am Charles Manson's
daughter I think they just tapped into
that I think people get amiss
understanding of what we are told okay
you know all those are given we know no
three sentences
mine was you're a feminist you hate
sororities period really and then you're
like okay and you start thinking about
it you start reading Gloria Steinem
books and this and then you get the
first script and it says you're you're
blackmailing a student for sex on
academic probation so it nothing adds up
you're not given any information you
can't build on anything yeah you don't
know anything really until you got the
script so you have to stay very loose
and fluid as a doctor you can't get
locked into some idea we also didn't
want it to inform we didn't want anybody
to know who the killer was because we
didn't want it to inform any of the
performances even it was important that
that you guys didn't know to keep it
open yeah Abigail were you I mean number
five was always sort of so upset and
frazzled were you like out of breath
constantly I mean was in training
because she was she's a fragile little
she's a lot it's I don't want to say
that it was difficult yeah for me
because it wasn't but it was definitely
I felt a little bit more because I
already have to deal with my own stress
and me as a person everyday and then I
had to deal with her stress too so I
would go home being extra exhausted no
it's a it was just fun it was fun to
just watch you can take it too far most
the time I hope not I don't know Leah
were you ever actually in the red devil
costume did you ever actually put it on
I know but we have a fantastic man named
Riley who played the Red Devil and then
we that when I sort of started to get a
little hint now that it was me that it
might be a woman was when they brought
in a female stunt double so here's a
couple scenes where the Red Devil was
like five feet tall yeah John have you
been to comic-con before
no I'm this is your first time you're a
comic-con virgin
Carrie great place to break my cherry
right here yes exactly exactly we're so
happy to all be here for you to get free
Thalia lose your virginity like do you I
mean this is all this place is all about
fandom do you kind of geek out on things
like are you do you love Star Wars are
you like a Trekkie are there things you
sort of like love like this I'm a Disney
geek interesting I have sign in your
yard have the host I bought the sign on
eBay they they just they stood right
when you may start at Disney to the
whole thing and I thought it was like I
did the initial bid like 35 grand I'll
never get this Michael Jackson alright
and then I ended up with it and and I
and I put just the D up behind my house
you know see sort of wouldn't say it and
then no but I didn't think up the whole
valley
so if you look up you see a big D from
[ __ ] lives up there I mean I mean
Michael Jackson called me and left the
message I didn't actually say hey John
you know you're saying cuz I really dig
your stuff Mike we should go to
Disneyland together you know I should
right that would have been a great
Instagram picture but I didn't go I know
it really was I was on ER and I didn't I
it was a message and I you know I didn't
answer the phone and he didn't leave a
number so so why did you want to join
scream queens how did this sort of come
about for you
excuse me why did you want to join
scream queens what was it about was the
role what was what sort of drew you to
this well the guys first of all Ryan and
Ian and Brad I was lucky enough to be on
Glee a little bit and a new normal and I
just loved their rhythm and and you know
their sense of humor it's brilliant and
my other show got cancelled and I barely
got the words out Fox you dirty rotten
seems like been screamin but I was so
grateful I was so excited I said yes and
then I called Brad and he was in Ireland
to see Bruce Springsteen yes I said what
am i doing alright I'll do anything
did you play a doctor cool I've done
that on you know and he said but you
you're gonna be the the recipient of the
world's first complete hand trance
plan was alright you know he said you
you may have a hand from a brilliant
surgeon or you may have a hand from a
squash player who killed his opponents
and then ate them
when do I show up man wait but it's you
know in just a few days of working on
here I I mean I always I love I admire
all these actors and actresses but this
is not an easy show to do and these
these people you see up here are so
brilliant they're so smart it's a
difficult show to do and it looks like
it may be easy they make it look easy
but it's it's a real challenge that I'm
really excited to be part of it yeah
Taylor what about you what drew you to
this a lot of the same in addition to
the fact that it it's completely
different for me I've never done
anything like this and I just wanted to
work with talented people and that
includes the creators of the show Ryan
and Brad and this whole cast Thank You
Taylor
welcome I wasn't talking about you but
team Jess your team Jacob let's hear it
thank you go ahead Taylor I'm team Jesse
if I defended so let's talk about season
two what can we say okay so it's set in
the hospital yeah and if that Hospital
is owned by Miz Cathy munch yeah Dean
Munsch parlays her fame based on her as
an icon of new movement called new new
feminism and her subsequent book tour
and parlay is that money into purchasing
a hospital it's sort of unclear what her
reasoning is there's a bit of a gray
area there yeah former asylum it's a
former song yeah but it's not the
hospital that the girls were in at the
end yeah and there's a three-year time
skip there's a three-year time job okay
and John is the head of surgery yes yes
your surgery yes she saw my layout and
Playgirl 10 hottest that's how
may Okanagan and tailors also a doctor
yes yes yes and he because so basically
then murders begin and you kind of
become the prime suspect right I do I
become the prime Ilana I don't know why
but yeah as soon as they land the the
killings start okay and zayday is now a
med student yes yes she is she's a med
student she got in there very very
quickly just took her year and a half
[Laughter]
much she you know Dean Munsch plucked
her out from wherever the obscurity that
she was after all the murders and you
know dealing with what happened in
season one yeah
and she says you know what I believe in
you and Zedd is like you know what I
thank you so I'm I'm willing to help you
out I think what's been most interesting
so far for all of us is that you know we
all thought okay season two we're back
at Kappa and yet honestly to be back at
Kappa would just feel redundant yeah all
jokes we've sort of seen it been there
done that and as soon as we started
working this you know drastic right turn
into this whole new world has completely
felt like oh of course we're here now
and everyone is exactly who they were
and the comedy is the same and the
characters are the same and yet the
world is really a hundred percent and
how do you guys make everything make
sense when it's so abstract like how do
you connect those dots
I took some work it wasn't it's not the
easiest to like totally switch I mean it
would be much easier to just keep the
premise you have to begin with but we
knew we wanted to switch it up really
each season have an entirely different
within the same world but an entirely
different setting so it was tricky
that's what that's what we were talking
about most like who okay so first of all
like who survived who can we use and who
who does it make sense can come into
this world and it wasn't everybody but
we were able to sort of justify the
moves into the hospital for for all the
cast that we have early on said it it
feels more accessible this season which
it does more relatable
doh yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
yeah we sort of encountered the chanels
rather than at the top of their game
down and out which is an interesting
sort of place to put them in a low
status position coming in and as they
have fallen from glamour yeah but
they're trying to hold on to it as much
as they can
we're like very simple life vibes
where'd you say very simple life I was
Paris in the cold yeah so it's a it's a
it's really funny seeing them try to you
know hold on to their style when they
have no money and kind of they have to
work which is something that's
completely foreign to them and and it's
it's it's hilarious it's fun they like
bedazzled their scrubs or like are they
like like what I mean how I said it's
funny you say that no they definitely
have some really cool Hospital gear
there's definitely some like first at
the scopes and rhinestones has a scope
there's definitely a lot of capes I was
like do people wear I don't know if
people wear a little caplets in like
florence night you're working in the
hospital that are pink but okay we'll go
with it
yeah I have piping on my Michael yeah
like this
Leah how does Hester fit into this when
we come back we don't know where Hester
is that's a question mark when you find
out you it's great when you guys pretty
good I'm I'm very happy I'm not with
these guys in the hospital okay is you
know but we do have scenes together and
I'm my costume is very comfortable and I
have a fun new accessory to play with
[Music]
and your eye your eye is better she's
yeah yeah and Abigail and Emma Chanel
and number five you guys were like
besties in the asylum which is you know
which was not the case before is that
relationship held well there weren't a
lot of choices in the asylum Wow
no we were besties and
you know I think what I love about the
chanels is that they're really mean to
each other but they somehow always stick
together no they're really means me me
it really means well they always stick
together and it's always funny because
no matter what happens you always still
see them just walking down the hallway
in that formation no matter what's been
said or done but no they're not there
they're not as besties but they're there
they're on good terms this season at
least in my notes my boyfriend Glen
Powell is not here what what's been with
Chad Radwell is he back sure is yeah
yeah wait what can you gonna say about
Chad what's Chad up to uh uh I think
he's a fantastic actor I've this the
script that I read I'm showering with
this young man
so I'm actually jogging my memory I'm
actually drawing a blank
you know I wrote it as he stole we we
are writing which is far ahead so I
actually forget where are he and Denise
still uh do they have any kind of
connection at all we know they had such
a horrible breakup right beautifully
gorgeous I mean one of one for the ages
yes he brings his friend back in the
second episode that's right that's right
yeah yeah yeah he's in with a friend
who's actually a patient at the hospital
and there are some celebrity patients
that are gonna appear this season yes
there are who might be some of these
delivery patients we have Colton Haynes
[Applause]
Olsen twins that'd be amazing can you
make a call I can't even get him on my
show
[Laughter]
and we're very excited about Cecily
strong
is Lee strong yeah it's a cavalcade our
our John and Taylor's characters are
they potential love interests for any of
these ladies yes their potential are
they do you guys have a favorite for the
chanels going back to season one do you
have a favorite outfit that you guys
wore something you got even
you know Leah for Hester or even you
know Kiki for zayday did you have a
favorite sort of look because there was
some real striking ensembles my favorite
look visiting was probably outside of
the when we first meet the ice cream guy
that I Coney yeah all right first time
with me koni and Dean Munsch is doing
that big speech and everybody's outside
with the candles I love say days out
honey she was all the gag the gag
started long time ago when the braids
were over the earmuffs oh they're
horrible time where I had I decided it
would be a really great idea to braid
over my muffs horrible muff prison for
the whole episode and it was like the
longest change ever I wore these mas for
literally ten days and that's like in
deep pain horrible it was a beautiful
outfit and a really good vision yeah you
saw my vision I mean I'm a huge fan of
the orange jumpsuit
oh I love it and the shackles I felt at
home wait a moment
[Laughter]
was yours oh I love I mean I love that
like anything with like a sad cat to
where when we did our first photo shoot
a couple of the like crew members who
we'd worked with on Glee that are now on
scream queens no one recognized
I loved everything I got to wear
including being Chanel number six I comb
my Chanel robe I loved I loved all the
cut the stuff that they like monogrammed
with Chanel and I thought was really
funny yeah yeah Jamie what is Cathy's
love life like this season because she
left we left season one and she was
still dating West but it three years
later are they going strong are they
they were dating but I think she was
jettisoning him okay you know I I don't
know let me ask hi in this Cathy have a
love life does Cathy have love in her
life I think so I think got a lot of
love in her like excellent all right
there's a lot of love at this table that
she can have in her life and I
and I don't discriminate nor do i
discriminate by gender I'm a FEMINIST
[Laughter]
all right Billy I have you talked to
your mom at all about coming on scream
queens cuz I would love to see Carrie
Fisher available she's available I'm
saying she would love it yeah genius
amazing
maybe she like have a little moment with
Charles Manson in the jail yes like a
little flashback yeah
you know Roxy yeah hmm I like your
grandma Debbie Reynolds your grandma
grandma oh she could do a little tap
dance into the hospital that could be
incredible you guys I see that vision a
hundred percent that's I would also love
if Gary Fisher could show up maybe you
could be another love interest of mine
because I'm pansexual so why not get
them in there is number three still
exploring her sexuality
she's always exploring yeah yeah yeah
man so she's got to get around the whole
pan yeah
[Laughter]
I think we're start taking audience
questions in like a few minutes so if
you guys want to start lining up I don't
know where the line our line is but yes
I want to know who do you think would
win in a fight Rachel Berry or Hester oh
good or to believe that Hester was in
the red devil costume at least once or
twice you know I might say Hester but
Rachel Berry shoes scrappy he could
Jerry she could definitely fight someone
if it was for the right part yeah
there's nothing like that they're both
pretty yeah absolutely
thanks Ian Ian who do you think would
win you created both those ladies I
think Hester they should have a sing-off
it'd be amazing there's no singing on
scream queens emma is there any chance
you could come back to American Horror
Story have you discussed that at all I
think that there might be I I was uh I
was going to last season and then we
were in New Orleans shooting supreme
queen so I couldn't but now we're both
in LA so maybe mmm I don't know I think
it brings me in might now no Intel we
have no information none no but I hope
so I love I mean I love that show so
much so I would love to go back and do a
few episodes so ents this this this next
season for us is it is it bloody year is
it funnier how do you sort of see it
forming right now I think it's bloodier
and funny or there's a more of a a sort
of what's the word it's Oman no rope
second a quantum where you sort of can't
something's gruesome but you can't sort
of stop looking at it I'm not gonna find
the word but yeah I think it's I think
we're yeah I feel like we're leaning
into the the creepiness a little bit
more and a little bit more into the
comedy as well I think it's a little bit
funnier and I didn't last season was
funny by my measure so yeah I think
funny and gruesome Prince Rexy is
yeah and what sexy and it's in a
hospital so yeah by nature is a scary
place yeah yeah and you know the how we
I was reminded that Halloween - yeah in
a hospital so there is definitely the
trope of hospitals hallways stainless
steel yeah sharp things blood I feel
like the mystery aspect with the killer
is much higher this season immediately
we knew okay Red Devil okay there's
somebody in the zoo we know okay we're
trying to figure who that guy is
but when in this one is like what's
going on well where's this happening and
why is this happening where are we you
know yeah and this is sort of a whole
new mystery not is this a mystery not
connected to the babies and everything
like is this sort of a whole new
mythology can't comment specifically how
about no that's a no comment okay
alright yeah I mean we're in the same
world okay the same universe
you